bonjour à toutes et à tous et sur toi
toi olivier qui devraient apprécier cet
épisode lui c'est émigra mousse blé riz
ou nez rouge de son petit nom c'est un
poisson originaire d'amazonie un poisson
d'eau douce qui a le nez rouge
et figurez vous que c'est une star chez
les chercheurs c'est une star c'est
parce qu'il est connu pour se déplacer
avec ses congénères en grands bancs de
poissons et surtout il adore nager à
contre courant et le nom scientifique
pour cette habitude c'est la raie aux
taxis et c'est le même mot qu'on utilise
pour les spermatozoïdes bon imaginez un
banc de poissons nagent en face au
courant à votre avis dans l'eau ça va
prendre quelle forme mois
instinctivement je vais plutôt penser à
une formation en triangle ou or en
diamants un peu comme les escadrille
d'avions 14 juillet où les oiseaux
migrateurs un truc bien aérodynamique
quoi il se trouve que l'art et aux taxis
est un sujet très étudiée en
hydrodynamique les modèles et les
expériences se base sur le calcul des
doublions créés par chaque poisson
l'idée est que lorsqu'un poisson âge ça
que va créer des tourbillons dans l'eau
environnante et ses tourbillons vont
affecter la neige je sais plus proche
voisin
ces modèles qui sont en deux dimensions
montre que la configuration qui garantie
la plus faible dépense en énergie des
poissons et celles dites en diamants bon
c'est plus ou moins conformes à ce que
j'imaginais tout va bien
une équipe de chercheurs de paris a
voulu tester ses résultats
expérimentalement et en trois dimensions
ils ont mis les petits nez rouge dans un
tunnel dos dans lequel circule en
courant dont ils peuvent contrôler la
vitesse ce qu'il ya de bien avec les nez
rouges c'est que comme ils nagent à
contre-courant
ils vont adapter leur vitesse à la
vitesse du courant qu'on leur impose
donc on peut savoir exactement à quelle
vitesse ils nagent et pour la petite
histoire les chercheurs mesurent 7
vitesses en longueur de poisson par
seconde
ici par exemple 0,8 longueur de poisson
par seconde à l'aide de caméras rapide
placée au dessus et sur les côtés du
tunnel
ils ont pu étudier individuellement et
en 3d la position de chacun des poissons
du groupe et ils ont mesuré l'amplitude
et la fréquence des battements de leurs
clips en fait le mouvement l'accueil est
un indicateur de l'énergie dépensée par
le poisson oui quand on remue la queue
moins vite on dépense moins d'énergie
c'est logique à faible vitesse les
chercheurs observent que les poissons
adopte comme prévu une configuration en
diamants mais quand la vitesse du
courant augmente la configuration du
banc change et il adopte une
configuration en pha l'anc ce petit
point culture fall hanks en grec ancien
phalange en français est une formation
militaire en ligne compacte de lanciers
lourdement armés conçu pour anéantir
l'infanterie et demi fazio fallon et là
vous vous dites sûrement comme moi mais
pourquoi
qu'est ce qui se passe dans leur petite
tête rouge contre toute attente quand le
courant augmente autour de quatre
longueurs de poisson par seconde
le banc serait organisant une ligne
compacte au sein de laquelle le
mouvement de chacun des poissons et
synchrone avec celui de ses voisins
en fait plus le courant augmente plus
l'effort à fournir pour maintenir la
vitesse de nage devient intense et c'est
à ce moment là que les poissons somme
est en formation fall hanks les
chercheurs ont remarqué que en se
positionnant ainsi la fréquence de
battement d que des poissons diminuent
ce qui veut dire que cette configuration
paraît particulièrement économe en
énergie
l'efficacité de la nage dans cette
configuration est intimement liés à la
synchronisation du mouvement de la queue
de chaque poisson avec ses plus proches
voisins
ainsi le mouvement de l'eau déplacés par
la queue de chaque poisson a un effet
positif sur le corps de ses plus proches
voisins qui fournissent alors moins
d'énergie pour déplacer leurs propres
que les chercheurs souhaitent maintenant
modélisé en trois dimensions
l'écoulement de l'eau lors de la nage
des nez rouges au sein d'un banc et
leurs résultats pourraient inspirer la
conception de petits robots nageurs bio
inspirée
voilà je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
trouver les sources de toutes ses études
dans la description
moi je vais partir avec rodolphe et je
vous laisse sur cette fin d'épisode en
queue de poisson
et et n'oublie pas à beaune toi